hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
klappt aber da ja gerade die
weihnachtszeit ist habe ich mir gedacht
ich noch eine winter folge ich habe auch
übrigens wieder hier meinen tollen
playmobil kalender am start das heißt
irgendwo im video werde ich das fünfte
türchen öffnen und wir fangen jetzt an
mit dem video ich hab hier wie immer
schon ein bisschen mit dem clever bot
gelagert um zu schauen ob er aktiv ist
ob der club kasten sein kopf drin und
jetzt stelle ich mal wieder die anfangs
frage ob der clever bot er noch
irgendwie klug ist und zwar welche farbe
hat mein t shirt da hat glaube ich
einmal richtig erraten die anderen male
war es komplett falsch immer dein
t-shirt hat die farbe glück
hey stunden bisschen ableiten in deinem
kopf aber das soll auch erst mal
komplett egal sein denn ich habe mir
halt gemacht
dezember weihnachten das wetter ist zwar
einfach nur komplett scheiße aber egal
habe ich mal ein bisschen weiter
nachgedacht und der clever bot weiß ja
nahezu alles wie der weihnachtsmann da
ich natürlich nicht direkt raus fragen
will auf der klever bot auch wirklich
der weihnachtsmann ist frage ich einfach
mal freust du dich auf weihnachten
stellt euch das mal einfach vor das ist
gar kein weihnachtsmann gibt sondern
einfach dass der clever bot ist er
weihnachten ist schon vorbei klar haben
wir jetzt wieder
nein weihnachten ist noch nicht vorbei
da braucht mich jetzt nicht so traurig
angucken hier wiegt schon noch eure
geschenke apropos weihnachten vor
weihnachten müsste auch wo ich gerade
mal hingeschaut habe müsste auch wieder
das shirt und der rudi und der sweater
und hier wieder alles im shop verfügbar
sein
tut mir leid aber das ist komplett alles
ausverkauft gewesen nach zwei stunden
die kriegen neue sachen am 16 dezember
glaube ich rein und ab da kann man
wieder bestellen und dann sind ja auch
innerhalb von drei spätestens vier tagen
bei euch das heißt noch vor weihnachten
und wahrscheinlich mit sticker und
autogramm da der clever bald wieder so
blöd war und meinte weihnachten ist
schon vorbei frage ich jetzt einfach mal
was frage ich denn jetzt mal wünscht du
dir etwas zu weihnachten lieber clever
bot das wäre natürlich immer schön zu
wissen weil dann könnte ich vielleicht
eine kleine freude machen sich außerdem
space gedrückt ich würde mal sagen das
ist noch zu weit weg
es sind noch 22 tage und wohin mein dass
du weihnachten jetzt auch schon vorbei
[ __ ] you klepper bot ich frag mal anders
und zwar was würdest du gerne unterm
baum liegen sehen ist kann ja leider
selbst oder seine krippe stehen und ein
bisschen geld oder er sagte er möchte
die playmobil adventskalender haben so
ein wie ich hier ich würde gerne deine
augen sehen
wels ecken slate com ein geschenk an den
kletterbaum
einfach mal um das gespräch mit den
aufzulockern schreibe ich mal mit einem
lächeln smiley es kann ja sein setzt
auch so schreibt sie
das geht natürlich habe ich wünsche ich
werde ein bisschen lockerer mit dir 16
ich jungs abblasen
ich bin raus ich habe den witz ja
schonmal gebracht dass ich hinter die
kamera geguckt haben gesagt hey leute
kommt nach weggang bock mehr ab dass an
da ist eine wand und eine tür dass das
war's ich habe da keine leute achten
lampe habe ich auch noch
da ich bin hier keine kein youtuber der
seinen seine ganzen aufgenommene sachen
an ihm den schickt und irgendwie anders
machen als ich
kriegt dafür ein like oder
kurz ich hab den clever wort jetzt
einfach mal gefragt wieso 16 es kann
nicht sein schreibt er schreibt 16 ich
schreibe so 16 uhr schreibt weil ich das
nicht verraten darf
alles klar ich habe gerade übels gute
idee wie ich so indirekt fragen kann ob
er der weihnachtsmann ist ich frage ihn
einfach hast du schon mal das rentier
rudolph gesehen weil der weihnachtsmann
hat natürlich relativ viele reden
clever bord
na ja gar nicht mehr sagen ich frage
jetzt einfach frei schnauze raus bist du
der weihnachtsmann ja aber sagt kaim
ich wusste es
ich habe es von anfang an gesagt was
würde nun ein erfahrener erwachsener
youtuber und ein im leben stehen da man
wie ich nun den weihnachtsmann fragen
was kriege ich zu weihnachten
weihnachten war gerade erst du musst
noch zehn monate warte
behindert was für zehn monate
in zehn monaten des oktobers
merkel wenn du schon krieg jetzt gegen
syrien findet dann bitte nicht über
meiner wohnung okay ich zitiere jetzt
einfach mal einen kleinen vers aus einem
tollen kinderlied zu weihnachten
weihnachtsmann sag mir warum bist du so
schlau woher kennst du ganz knapp
darunter clever beantwortet weil ich ein
mensch bin
an dieser stelle würde ich mal sagen
dass wir das fünfte türchen aufmachen um
mein gott das ist ja mit eines der
größten türchen hier das fünfte türchen
war das hier unten das war riesig groß
und in die tierchen haben wir
dementsprechend quasi nur etwas ganz
klein leise ich habe hier zwei
hantelstange und ein
ich war
den wollte ich eigentlich cool gerade so
rum schnitzler hat nicht ganz geklappt
aber ich weiß was das sein soll und zwar
mache ich das hier so dran dann mache
ich das hier unten auf malta hatten wir
ja meine ich im video vom 2 vom dritten
dezember aber da die ersten drei türchen
aufgemacht weil der kalender zu spät
ankam da hatten wir so ein kleines
kleidchen und das können wir jetzt hier
so daran aufhängen und dann haben wir so
ein kleider
es ist das funktioniert tatsächlich
sogar richtig gut ja das ist ja toll das
kommt erst mal
zu den anderen sachen da unten und dann
würde ich auch sagen beenden wir dieses
video an dieser stelle wie haben heute
herausgefunden clever bord ist der
weihnachtsmann
wenn euch das gefallen hat würde ich
mich definitiv über eine bewertung
freuen weil in diesen videos immer sehr
viel mühe drin steckt und auch mit dem
adventskalender und blabla und macht zu
erringen